I heard his footsteps following me and I
was heading for the end of the road
and as I walked faster I could hear his
footsteps getting faster and faster
and then sheer Panic took over
and I started to run towards the end of
the road and as I ran I could feel his
his steps getting nearer and nearer and
nearer so close behind me I had the
hairs on the back of my neck standing up
and my knees went to jelly
[Music]
so it was 25th of October and I planned
to go into town to meet my friends
on a Saturday night as we usually did
just for a few beers Leeds was a really
vibrant town
full of music venues Arty people my
boyfriend at the time went on a CND
March which was a campaign for nuclear
disarmament
so I was on my own which was fine and I
got ready I got the flat old tidy so it
was nice when I came back and went to
meet my friends to plan my 21st birthday
party which was up and coming in a few
days time there was an atmosphere in
Leeds at the time whereby you didn't
want to stay out late and women were
encouraged not to go out alone well I
wasn't having any of that as a 20 year
old I just thought that was ridiculous
and I felt very safe and Street wise so
my friends decided that we should leave
the pub early we'd ran out of money to
be filled and had enough money for a few
beers and then I separated from them to
walk into the Town Center to catch my
bus home
so they were fretting a bit saying are
you going to be all right you can
absolutely fine there's nothing to worry
about I'm just going into town catch a
bus get home to the flat and I'll be
okay so I went on my own through the
Leeds University campus
there was a few people about it wasn't
particularly busy I think people had
already gotten home
and then I thought if I don't hurry I'm
gonna miss my bus
so I took a shortcut which was only a
side street it wasn't an alley or
anywhere dark and then I heard this
voice behind me just here
it was a really friendly friendly voice
and he said hi Hi how are you doing I
thought I'm bound to know this person
they're probably on Route into town like
me or their you know fellow student so I
turned around and went and walked
towards him and as I got closer I didn't
recognize him at all
I noticed that he was holding himself
really oddly
as though he was
he had an arm around his side and he was
leaning a little bit but he really
wanted to engage in conversation that
much I do remember
and I I started to feel a little bit
uncomfortable
and so I said no I'm sorry yeah bye I've
got to catch a bus and I I turned round
and started to walk very quickly
then I sensed real danger because I
heard his footsteps following me
and I was heading for the end of the
road
and as I walked faster I could hear his
footsteps getting faster and faster and
then sheer Panic took over
and I started to run towards the end of
the road and as I ran I could feel his
his steps getting nearer and nearer and
nearer so close behind me I had the
hairs on the back of my neck standing up
and my knees went to jelly and then I
felt this massive blow to the top of my
head and I just saw
I just saw the ground coming up towards
me and I was made completely unconscious
I'm sorry no it's fine it's got to be
sad
apparently unbeknownst to me as I don't
remember anything apart from the blow to
my head and falling to the ground I let
out a scream fortunately there was a
young couple walking at the end of the
road
right where I needed to get to and then
they saw me on the floor with this man
kneeling over me wielding something and
trying to hit me repeatedly and they ran
towards him and at that point he saw
them
and ran away and if it wasn't for them
he would have had his final blow and I
wouldn't I wouldn't be sat here today
for sure
what were the injuries you sustained
so the injuries that I sustained were I
had two massive dents to the top of my
head
um
my jaw was cracked open completely I bit
the side of my tongue the inside of my
mouth needed stitches
I had a fractured skull fractured
cheekbones and two puncture wounds to
the nape to the the top of my
top of my neck just underneath my skull
which I learned later had only just
missed my spinal cord these were a
sharpened screwdrivers that he'd rammed
up inside
while I was on the floor basically you
know I had a big big gash on on the side
of my eye that needed stitching up and
it was all about my head my head was
just full of cuts and bruises scars and
broken jaw and was pretty pretty
horrific
to the point where when my parents
eventually came to the hospital
um
they didn't recognize me
so I I was in hospital bed thinking
there's mom and dad and my dad had his
cap in his hand and they were walking
there was only like four beds in this
Ward
and they were like well where is she and
I'm like I couldn't speak because my jaw
was so my my face was so swollen I was
on unidentifiable on my hair
was covered in blood you know so much
blood
um I think they'd cleaned my face but my
hair was all matted and then they saw me
and I saw their faces and then I I
started to realize something very
serious that happened to me
so at what point of time did you start
realizing who was the attacker
so
following the injury and knowing that
there was this man called the Yorkshire
Ripper on the streets
I did not want to be associated with
with that with that kind of
serial killer Mass hysteria that was
going on at the time
the Yorkshire Ripper was seen as a a
serial killer who was cleaning up the
streets of women who were working in the
night so it was for the sex industry for
women who were on the streets
and for some bizarre and twisted reason
the police in the early days thought let
him do it let him carry on he's doing
Society a favor you know these women
aren't really worth that much their
lives are aren't worth anything and then
he started to kill women students
Housewives
all kinds of all kinds of women
from all walks of life
at the time they they the police uh
they're called the the Ripper Squad were
transported up from London and became
the the chief uh superintendent who was
head of the the whole of the Ripper
investigation
uh these four men uh received a tape
recording and it was taunting them that
they couldn't find the Ripper and they
believed that this tape was from the
Ripper himself
and they also received letters saying
things like you can't find me Jack it
was very personal to the man who was who
was in charge of the of the Ripper Squad
and he he took this very very seriously
so he put all his eggs in one basket for
this one tape recording and a few
letters and decided to do this massive
campaign all around the city where they
they magnified the the letters and put
them on billboards do you know this
handwriting they played the tapes in
working Men's Clubs shopping centers on
the bus you could hear it everywhere it
was this Geordie accent then you'll
never catch me really really taunting
very very frightening and then they
started to interview everyone who had a
tind side accent or a Geordie accent and
dismissed what the officers on the
ground were saying that they knew that
he wasn't a Geordie that he was a
yorkshireman who had been this uh this
serial killer
so the Ripper Squad decided to ignore
all the men on the ground all the
detectives there and every now and then
and I've learned this most recently when
they did go to the chief Constable at
the time they were told in no uncertain
terms if you mention that this was a
Yorkshire man ever again you you they're
all young detectives you're going back
on traffic you're going back on the beat
and that was it so they were gagged they
couldn't they couldn't communicate to
the the Ripper Squad they weren't having
any of it they invested all of their
Research into this this hoax tape but
the police in their wisdom at the time
so they thought it would be best to
really play down my attack because
um they were being heavily criticized by
the media and the public and the
government for not being able to to find
this serial killer
so
um they said it wasn't him
to me it couldn't have been him it was
just a random attack but that was to
help them show that they weren't
incompetent so they played it right down
and said it definitely wasn't the
Yorkshire Ripper
how did it feel for you to be out there
knowing that the manhood actually wasn't
caught how did you get on with that with
your life
so I returned from hospital after
intensive care and
my jaw I was wired up so I could not
just speak like this it was really
difficult
and
I thought well hang on a minute they're
not taking my
my attack seriously
so that means there's someone out there
who wants to finish me off
because he didn't get to the point where
he killed me because I managed to escape
so I tried to carry on went back to the
art studios it was my final year I had
lots of etchings and print making to do
and I did not want anything to get in
the way of that
but deep down inside I was really really
frightened and I carried on getting on
the bus and I wouldn't go out at night
no one went out at night there if you
just meet up for a coffee in in town and
during the day and I became more and
more uh isolated and depressed even
though I was with my very caring
boyfriend at the time
two months after I was attacked
a young student was killed and I do
strongly believe that if they'd listened
to me and investigated me and taken my
case more seriously that Jacqueline Hill
would have would not have been attacked
and they would have found
who was then known as Peter Sutcliffe
they would have found him and and put
him under lock and key
I lost a lot of confidence
but I was doing my art degree which is
the thing that I loved and that was
that was what was keeping me going
but it was it was very demoralizing to
think that nothing was happening and
another person was attacked shortly
after me and then another
and the students they put on their
student buses to transport women around
the town
there was a reclaim the night March
because we were all so in
so
alarmed that Margaret Thatcher the prime
minister at the time was saying you
women you shouldn't be going out on your
own you have to have you know you've got
to be accompanied by a man and it's it's
ill advice for you to go out alone so
the women of Leeds decided to um do a
reclaim the night March and we went out
and marched through the streets and said
that it's the fact that men that should
be uh
put into to keep that home and and not
the women and it was quite a magnificent
and very empowering statement which was
broadcast nationally
how was he called Peter Sutcliffe was
caught by accident by a Bobby on the
beat who noticed that he had the wrong
number plates on his car
and the policeman you know told him to
pull over asked him a few questions
noticed there was a young woman beside
him in the car so Clifford decided he
wanted to take a leak while he was being
um
pressed in with these charges against
the vehicle
a condition
and the policeman went back and found
screwdrivers and hammers that suck Cliff
had disposed of while he was being
interviewed for this uh this car offense
and that's when they that's when they
caught him
so it was by accident and it was just by
wasn't by detective work it was just
purely by accident
how does it make you feel when he was
called
well it was really strange when Peter
Sutcliffe was caught across
I I honestly had no communication with
the police they weren't coming to me to
say yeah we caught him this is the man
who tried to kill you because they said
that it wasn't Peter Sutcliffe who'd
attacked me
so I was still in a
frame of mind
that my attacker was still out there so
I I couldn't get over that I didn't have
any justice I couldn't feel safe
and every time I went into town I would
get my keys and put key through each
finger and made a fist so if I saw the
man again that attacked me I would you
know be able to to attack him back
as the media went on and his face
appeared on the screens
that's when I recognized
and I was at home alone in Liverpool
recuperating from my my injury still
and I saw his face and I thought that's
the man
that's that's the man who tried to talk
to me and
befriend me
but I couldn't I couldn't tell anyone I
was so frightened
what are people going to think
you know me as a Young art student
that I would been I'd been attacked
because they'd assumed that I was a a
prostitute
so I kept it hidden and because the
police weren't coming to me
I thought well it is it him and I
started to doubt myself and I thought
the best thing to do
would be to just go into denial you know
mo
that it's him the police aren't saying
anything
and I just I did that for for a number
of years mum and dad had no idea it was
Sutcliffe I didn't tell anyone about it
I told him about the attack but I didn't
say I think it was by the Yorkshire
Ripper Peter Sutcliffe I did not want to
be labeled as a victim of the Yorkshire
Ripper no way I did wonder at some point
whether I was going to get that phone
call from the West Yorkshire police to
confirm deep down what I already knew
the the police at the time were thinking
well we've we've got him we've caught
him uh
whoever else he attacked we don't know
we've got some records of some people
and uh but that's not important because
they're all right now aren't they
about 10 or 12 years ago he did confess
to one young lady who he attacked
so they managed to get a confession out
of him
and chief Constable Keith Halliwell did
go to him and ask him
uh if he had attacked me
and the Chief Inspector knew Sutcliffe
knew but Sutcliffe was not going to say
anything
so he was holding his cards close to his
chest
and then he died about a year or so ago
and I knew I knew he'd taken that secret
to the to his grave
and that that was pretty heartbreaking
and I've had to accept that
but
you know I never got a confession so
even in his prison cell sock Cliff did
whole power
over his other other assaults and he
knew full well what he'd done
but he liked to just sit back and
conductive lie his life in prison
I think it made him feel powerful
that he'd attacked other women but the
police hadn't convicted him for it
and that's I find really sickening even
though it was convicted for murder he
got away with assaults he got away with
with the most disgusting crimes
and and that shouldn't that shouldn't
have happened
there's a kind of outrage that while he
did Kill A lot of people Sutcliffe you
know murdered many women and attacked
many women
there were even more that the police had
rushed to one side and not taken their
cases seriously because it's really
really hard to
to go through your life the attack was
one thing being ignored by the police is
another
but not being able to get Justice
and the respect
and and to be ignored
that's that just adds insult to injury
really written in my books
it's it's not good policing to say the
least and it's certainly not
victim-centered and it's certainly not
helping women who've been affected by
crime because what it indicates is that
women who have been affected by violent
crime are second-class citizens if we'd
all be men I just wonder if it'd be sat
here today protesting about the
injustice
would you say that this attack changed
your life
you know I've been I've had a lot of
counseling over the years
it's made me less trusting of people
it's made me very cautious of men
um I did have a a loving relationship
with a woman for 28 years
um I'm single now that's fine
but it did it did shape me and it but it
I think the most important thing that it
did give me that attack that five
minutes in the wrong place gave me the
uh
power to just go wow I I was I could I
nearly died I nearly died I was so close
to death and a horrific death it would
have been as well mutilated I just
that's it gave me power actually it
didn't it's it doesn't Define me because
I am other things than a victim of a
crazy serial killer you know I'm a
professional I'm a practicing artist I'm
a published author Sutcliffe couldn't
take that away from me he might have
broken my bones and tried to kill me and
you know the police didn't investigate
and the shame of all of that
but it did change me because it gave me
a Lust For Life it gave me
are like wow I survived that almost a
responsibility to carry on you know
harder uh and loud to shout louder to
make big art to do things and I I just
wonder how I would applauded on
if if I hadn't been attacked harness
your anger harness you you
your fear and and turn it around if you
can and use it as fuel to get you where
you want to be in your life it's really
vital that you you don't let it subsume
you and drown you and Define you
[Music]
he got hold of me and uh he said we
reckon there's probably about 30 victims
oh and uh I said 500 victims I said
that's probably what it's more like and
don't forget I've been investigating
several now for a year